nate the roads didn't seem too wet on my
way in this morning but
boy travel through the mountains today
is going to be tricky
absolutely right and the nevada highway
patrol does have an update for us first
a look at the overall freeway map it is
staying green and that is the good news
we are seeing some damp roads here and
there
after shutting it down for less than an
hour nevada highway patrol has reopened
the main road between prompt and las
vegas state highway 160
is back open at mountain springs they
had it closed between tacopa and state
highway 159
but there's still snow in the area
they're saying hey it's not a free ride
you got to be very careful
and the radar map showing possibly some
sprinkles on the east side of town
do you have a crash working now this is
the on ramp to get onto the south 15
from flamingo
live camera showing it is a dry road
there but watch for those flashing
lights
and again sherry and i will be keeping
you posted on wet damp roads all around
town
you've got to give yourself enough time
to get where you're going and please
leave space between you and all the cars
around you